commence avec cette manifestation
aujourd'hui du personnel des industries
électrique et gazière parmi les
revendications la création d'un service
public de l'énergie
certains dénoncent le projet grand odf
le projet de réforme du fournisseur
d'électricité un rassemblement qui a
déjà commencé on va se rendre sur place
avaient pour retrouver notre reporter
estelle phare dans le cortège et celle
bonjour alors quel est le mot d'ordre de
cette manifestation
et bien clairement s'inventa de
s'opposer au projet de restructuration
de df et dn j il avait été un temps à
nommer projet hercules pour finalement
s'appeler grant edf j'ai prévoit de
diviser le groupe en trois entités
distinctes objectif à permettre à edf
d'assurer à sa transition vers les
énergies renouvelables
elle met aussi remonter les finances du
groupe puisque edf est très endettée
mais pour elle les syndicats il s'agit a
purement et simplement d'un
démantèlement je propose de les écouter
je manifeste mon mécontentement pour
lutter conserver notre statut national
d'edf gdf qui date de 1946 on veut
garder parce que c'est essentiel pour le
fleuron le fleuron l'un des fleurons de
l'industrie française
et puis pour l'intérêt général des
usagers des abonnés ce projet est
néfaste pour les services publics parce
qu'on a des structures est complètement
le
le service public on privatise ce qu'ils
rapportent
et ce qui finalement va coûter eh bien
on nationalise et c'est les français qui
vont payer
c'est là c'est là que c'est scandaleux
on veut nous faire un service en groupe
comme les autoroutes ou les privés
peuvent intervenir dans le
dans le système en fait lui
intervenir dans la gestion en fait du
réseau alors c'est un service qui doit
être en gros géré par l'état raison
qu'ils étaient payés par les français
alors vous l'aurez compris samantha plus
globalement il appelle à la création
d'un service public de l'énergie sco des
timings et bien il s'agit d'un moment
fatidique et stratégique c'est en tout
cas ce qu'a expliqué la cgt ait fana me
qui organisait cette manifestation
manifestation qui prend la cgt 1 qui
espère peser sur le choix des manuels
macron qui devrait a scellé le sort de
l'entreprise donc être d'ici à la fin du
mois du côté cortège il s'était lancé
aux alentours de midi de la place de la
nation direction république lieu de
dispersion merci beaucoup
c'était le faire je vous laisse suivre
ce cortège sous la pluie même si là vous
êtes abriter